[Music]
I ain't being hey what's up cutie want
to go to dinner with sure
hey what about now I'm okay thank you
all right
you want to go now I mean yeah I'm not
doing anything and I just broke up with
my boyfriend just now too bad I don't
like tractor diggers
[Music]
you scare me
you scare so easily oh okay so you're
not scared of anything
nothing you're not scared of that spider
on your shoulder right that huge spider
it's very this is a chihuahua on my
shoulder do you feel that you're not
you're not afraid no I'm not scared
where is it and now it's getting a feel
ski on your boob unappropriate look like
it's going for your jugular now who
needs that you know you're right you're
nuts good for you not afraid that is
really huge I mean where did that spider
come from how old is he
I'm good now I guess I'm just gonna head
off to work
see ya wouldn't want to be a loser such
a fun day today I know best friends
forever
what's a squad name the three musketeers
[Music]
okay
best friends forever best friends
forever
let's go get some ice cream don't make
you feel
hey I'm on my period it's like a
massacre well call me Dexter girl so
good I pooped my pants it's running down
my leg it's like a muddy river it's like
a landslide in there like a [ __ ] neato
in there red and brown it's like a
freaking Picasso weirdo do you guys like
chocolate well I got a lot in my pants
85% crack aah what was that for
I could kill you with these hands oh I
studied where on YouTube he's scared
no it would be what are you doing just
showing you is boss
I'm gonna break free and three classic
move yep your week I have the element of
surprise I fell asleep hey guys it's me
Amanda Cerny thank you so much for
watching my certainty skits and liking
and commenting I literally read every
single one of them so thank you guys
team journey is growing and I love it
and want to involve you guys even more
so what I'm doing now is I'm taking sir
nice kit suggestions ideas paints you
just comment below and these good ideas
that you have for me and if I decide to
choose your idea that will shout you out
in my next sir nice kit youtube video so
keep the comments coming and who knows
it could be you love you guys and I'll
see you next week